You gain some experience with
the media player APIs, but
you may have just copy and pasted
the lines of code that you needed.
And you probably still have some
questions about how exactly it
all works.
So, let's talk about that now.
So, the media player is a complex class,
because it can play both audio and
video files.
So, these media files can
be bundled with the app,
just like how the song file was
included in our simple app earlier, or
they can be streamed from the Internet.
To give you an idea of how much
the media player is capable of,
here's the list of all the different
file types that the media player on
Android can support.
So, you see here we can have MP3, AAC,
WAV files, and much, much, much more.
By the way, the file types are just
different approaches to storing audio in
a digital form, all while minimizing
file size and maintaining sound quality.
So, this is similar to how there
are different image types such as JPEG,
GIF, PNG and etc.
So, in the case of the MYEQ app, we're
going to provide you with MP3 files
of Andrea speaking the words aloud.
This way, you can include
the files within the app and
they don't need to be
streamed from the Internet.